Hôm nay, hàng năm tàn chiến Trung Quốc đang tập trung khắp phục hộ quản nặng nè
mà cơn báo ra gà xa để lại chiếm un ngay sâu khi cơn bảo độ bộ
tại thành quảng đông, hàng chăm nghiên người dân mắt đầu sọt sệ nhà cơ
như trường học và suân nghiệp nối lại hoạt động.
Chính phủ Trung Quốc đã phát bộ hơn 1,5 chiến trịu đô lắm ý
để phụ gồm tắc cứu nạn và hỗ trợ cái địa phương bị anh hưởng.
Con tại hôm gân, lượng trưng nạn thần trường sọt sẹp kê độ, biển quảng cáo hương hay
đồng thời khó phục hệ thống sọt thông sân nay và trường học.
Còn báo đất hiện một chăm người bị thương và gần một gên người phải đi chủ ăn.
Châu khi đó tại đây loàn bảo ra gà xa, tây thải nhé trọng hơn
với nhất mình bệnh người thích mặt, hàng chương người bị thương và 2,5 người có mất tích.
Các nỗ lực tìm kìm cương hộ và nát đuổi trình khai.
Những gì bế này cho thấy mức độ tàn phá lớn của bảo ra gà xa, đồng thời đàn xa
tích thông nhau cho công tắc ở phó kinh tài tại khu vực.